Guten Morgen Linus.
Ist doch dein Podcast. Der Linus Neumann Podcast, das weiß jeder. LNP.
Zwanzigste Folge.
Name steht für Qualität.
Internet.
Folge, ja, ist Hammer, oder? Ja. Hätte das gedacht.
Ja. Ja, wer hätte das gedacht? Und, und, oh, und das, obwohl wir hier grundsätzlich eigentlich immer nur schlechte Nachrichten zu verkünden haben.
Euer schlechte Nachrichten-Podcast.
Ja
Zunächst ähm, ach so, ich habe letzte letzte Folge die Errater für die davor Folge vergessen. Möchte ich gerne kurz nachholen. Und zwar heißt das nicht EU GH, sondern EuGH.
Weil das nichts mit der EU wahrscheinlich zu tun hat.
Europäische Gericht.
Und dann gibt's ja noch diesen Menschenrechtsgerichtshof, der ist wiederum damit nicht, das ist wieder ein anderer, muss man auch aufpassen,
welche Gerichtshilfe das da sind. Aber wir haben ja zum Glück genug Juristen, die bei äh meiner offensichtlichen Schwäche für alles, was mit Gesetzen zu tun hat, ähm Schwäche bei allem, was mit Gesetz nicht für. Ähm,
dann schnell eine E-Mail schreiben.
Reingrätschen,
gerne gesehen, also äh nicht ohne Grund äh fordern wir hier zur Kollaboration auf. Und jetzt auch vielleicht ein weiteres Mal, also wenn ihr,
sachdienliche Hinweise habt, Tipps und äh auch so Themen, die man mal aufgreifen sollte, die sich vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt so aus dem Mainstream, den Mainstream äh aufdrängen
dann sind wir dafür auch äh offen. Wo wir gerade bei der Federkorrektur sind, äh noch ein Hinweis, ich,
Habe äh ich habe mir selber die letzte Sendung dann noch mal angehört und war ein bisschen unglücklich mit meiner Namenswahl und habe sie dann nachträglich geändert. Das hat einige Leute verwirrt. Es hat auch einige Podcast verwirrt. Obwohl das nicht hätte geschehen sollen.
War mal ein interessantes äh Experiment zu sehen, was passiert, aber das dupliziert dann halt irgendwie anders, auf einmal gibt's äh zwei Flatterknöpfe äh und sonstige Konfusionen
aber es war nötig. Es äh war ein Schritt, der getan werden musste und äh da bin ich dann sehr prinzipienfest. Deswegen haben wir sie umbenannt
denn das war irgendwie der Name, der sich eigentlich herausgestellt hat. Manchmal ist es ganz gut, wenn man sich nochmal sein eigenes Material anhört.
Also ich ich höre ja nicht meine eigenen Podcasts. Ist ja nicht, natürlich. Ja, doch, ich höre das nachher schon noch mal immer an. Äh ja, hallo Linus, ich grüße dich hier als Hörer auch. Gleichzeitig als Sprecher, wenn du das dann gleich nochmal hörst.
So, kommen wir, kommen wir mal, kommen wir mal.
Bezug nimmt, andere Form an.
Kommen wir zu den Themen.
Genau. Womit geht's los?
CISPA.
Oh, ein neues Wort.
Nach nach Pieper, Sopa haben wir jetzt.
Ist keiner so richtig überrascht gewesen, dass er jetzt so einen neuen Term dafür aufgelegt haben, oder? Mhm.
Ein neues Sternchenpaar, ja. Diesmal äh Cyber Intelligent Sharing and Protection Act. Ähm,
Da geht also es geht also darum, dass irgendwie Firmen und Regierungen im Computersystemen möglichst äh Monitorin filtern und blockieren können sollen im Dienste der Cyber Security, aber auch für andere Zwecke,
und diese Daten, die dabei anfallen, irgendwie untereinander teilen, aber vor vor allem mit dem Staat.
Also ist denn jetzt vielleicht kurz den Kontext erläutern? Also, wir hatten irgendwie Sofa und Pieper, die beiden ja, irgendwie.
Urheberrechts.
Separat entwickelten beide irgendwie das Gleiche betreffen, denn äh äh Legislaturs da in den USA, die dann aber am Protest gescheitert ist.
Genau, also einer kam eben aus einer kam aus dem Senat, einer kam aus dem Haus of Representivs
und ähm da gab's dann große Aufschreier. Jetzt letztendlich
wenden sich ja sogar große Urheberrechtsverbände dann gegen Soa. Ja, die, die ihn ursprünglich unterstützt haben und wahrscheinlich sogar eher lobbyiert haben, äh stellen sich jetzt irgendwie reihen sich ein und sagen, wir wollen, wir wollen den nicht
so. Also dieses Sofa ist jetzt irgendwie erledigt und äh Pieper wohl auch, also den weiß man ja immer noch Pieper. Protect,
äh was war denn? Wofür stand die Nummer pipa? Ich weiß immer nur, äh stop online und.
Ich schaue mal nach.
Für den Chemnitz.
Personal Information Protection nein, Entschuldigung. Äh das war das Andere. Äh Protect IP Act, entschuldig.
Achsoct IP, ja genau. Genau.
Die intellektual Popertie oder schütze das IP-Paket.
Ja, das sollte sich mal jemand drum kümmern. Die sind ja auch vom Aussterben bedroht.
Genau. Also ein alternatives Pieper starten irgendwie so.
So äh genau und jetzt äh geht's also um Cyber Intelligence, ja also.
Aber inwiefern ist klar, dass es sich hierbei jetzt wirklich um eine Neuauflage des selben Kuchens handelt oder ist das wirklich eine ganz andere Stoßrichtung?
Das ist schon eine ist ist eine andere Stoßrichtung, aber letztendlich in die gleiche Richtung. Also es wird jetzt eigentlich über andere, es wird jetzt anders begründet
und zwar da kommt's nämlich genau an. Sie sagen also, wir wollen irgendwie
Cyber-Intelligence, ja also ähm da geht's also eigentlich um um Intelligence, also Intelligence, ja das äh nachrichtendienstliche Informationen oder so, wird Intelligence ja eigentlich äh erfasst
und ähm Cyber-Kriminalität, Cyber-Terror und so, ne, dass jetzt auch das große neue Ding, Cyberwa,
ne? Und äh explizit wird dann darin Bezug genommen auf das Verteilen von Geheimdienstlich relevanten Informationen, also ein ganz klarer Bezug zu ähm Wiki Leaks, ne? Dass sie also sagen,
äh the sharing or sharing of Classify Intelligence. Ja, also
hundert Prozent Wiki Leaks, Krypto oder was, ne,
äh Dinge, auf denen draufsteht oder irgendwelche Geheimhaltungslevel. Ähm das muss eben bekämpft werden und da sollen eben alle äh Möglichkeiten offen sein. Es gibt also relativ klaren Wikileaksbezug dadrin.
Und außerdem ähm in Bezug auf Cyber, Fred Intelligence, also Cyber-Bedrohungs ähm,
Wissen oder äh geheimdienstliches Wissen oder so. Und da geht's also dann darum, was was also äh betrifft, Bedrohung für Regierung und Privatpersonen.
Die da drin äh,
münden könnten, dass deren Computersysteme geschwächt werden zum Aussatz äh gebracht werden oder äh zerstört werden. Also, sagen wir mal Hackerangriffe letztendlich, ja? Das das würde also äh Dedos bis äh bis tatsächliches,
Voll zerstören und Daten extrahieren wieder äh beinhalten. Und das dann in Bezug auf äh Regierung, persönliche Daten und geistiges Eigentum, was dann so,
Quasi dann das geistige Eigentum ist jetzt so ganz tief in den Nebensatz äh.
Kriegst das so nochmal so von hinten reingeschoben.
Genau, ganz unten tief im Nebensatz verschwunden. Letztendlich ähm aber kann man sagen, ein sehr klarer äh,
so definiert, dass es Wiki Leaks und Pirate Bay am Ende genau betrifft, ja? Also wenn du ähm Pirate Bay hast du also sicherlich bei vielen dort angebotenen äh Torwrens äh Urheberrechtsverletzungen,
und die zweite Schiene würde sich ergeben, natürlich ist nicht auszuschließen und ist sicherlich auch der Fall, dass über Pirate Bay ähm.
Sagen wir mal, Viren verseuchte äh Dateien in Umlauf gebracht werden, ja? Oder also es hindert mich ja keiner daran, vielleicht irgendwie, sagen wir mal, ein ein beliebtes äh Softwarepaket mit einem Trojaner zu vermischen und ähm,
dann auf Pirate zu stellen und so für die Versorgung äh Verbreitung meines meines Trojaners zu sorgen. Ähm,
beziehungsweise wenn da selbst wenn jetzt der die Situation wäre, dass das noch nie auf der Welt geschehen ist, würde es würde niemand,
stünde es den Menschen frei, dies zu tun und dann hättest du quasi zwei Ansatzpunkte gegen,
um dagegen vorzugehen und nach diesem Sister eben ja
das komplette Arsenal äh der digitalen Überwachungs- und Blockademaßnahmen irgendwie ans äh
anzuführen und gleichzeitig als Regierung so eine quasi ein ein Gesetz zu haben, auf das du dich berufen kannst, wenn du dann Daten extrahieren möchtest von anderen Anbietern. Ja oder also Daten bekommen möchtest, was weiß ich. Ähm.
Sei es jetzt Amazon, wo wirklich gehostet hat oder was auch immer, ne? Also, dass man, dass man sagt so, wir wollen da jetzt eine breite Basis haben, um gegen sowas vorzugehen. Letztendlich äh,
Gleicher Wein in neuen Schläuchen und jetzt steht halt irgendwie Cybersecurity dran. Ist ja auch immer eine Schiene, die gerne gefahren wird. Ja, Security relevant. Ähm.
Klar, so Gefährdung. So, das ist halt diese diese permanente Gefahr im Verzug, weil es könnte so nur für den Fall, dass es sein könnte, dass ein Hackerangriff droht. Genau. Sozusagen immer.
Und auch ähm die glaube ich wahrscheinlich das älteste Propaganda äh gegen halt Eberrechtsverletzung ist eben auch dieses so verbreiten sich Viren, ne. Das war, glaube ich, ne, also in im Softwarebereich,
dass man also die die Sorge vor vor dem Virus, dass das durchs Internet geistert, dass durch durch die Kopieren von Disketten.
Okay, aber welche Ermächtigung ist jetzt mit diesem Cispa äh verbunden? Also geht's jetzt wieder um genau dieselbe Geschichte mit Finanzströme blockieren.
Nee, äh also in diesem Fall bezieht sich's wirklich so auf Netzwerke, ne. Also wie gesagt, Monitoring, äh Filtering und Blocking.
Abschalten. Sollten wir uns zumindest erstmal abschalten kann. Das heißt, diese andere Idee mit äh äh wir wir kapern jetzt auch einfach mal den Money Flow. Ist jetzt zumindest hier so nicht mit drin.
Das kann's ja, glaube ich, also dieses mit dem Money Flow,
steht da glaube ich ähm kann sein, dass das irgendwo auch noch. Nee, steht ist keine Rede von von Geld. Das das kannst du ja ohnehin irgendwie äh machen, ne? Da brauchst du glaube ich wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal unbedingt ein neues Gesetz für oder vielleicht auch, aber ähm,
Das wird ja auch viel mehr versucht, über Absprachen,
untereinander irgendwie zu machen, ne? Dass man also sagt, wir wollen einfach nicht mehr, dass da Anzeigen geschaltet werden,
oder das war ja in einer in ein in anderen Gesetz, deswegen, dass man dahin geht. Hier geht's wirklich dann um um Überwachung und ähm.
Irgendwie Zucht und Ordnung ins Internet zu bringen, ja? Hm,
Soll dann eben also äh soll irgendwie auch ein Bezug dann zum National Security-Act von neunzehnhundertsiebenundvierzig haben und denen quasi in so eine neue Ebene drücken. Also.
Tut sich da jetzt im Widerstand? Also ich glaube, die IFF ist da schon Herr hörig.
Hat sich damit auseinandergesetzt und äh gibt jetzt wieder eine AVAS äh,
Petition und aber irgendwie wohl auch eine bisher schon recht große Unterstützerzahl im,
wo das Ding herkommt, ja. Ähm das heißt, da da haben wir wirklich genau die gleiche Situation wieder, ja?
Hm
Tja, dreht sich so ein bisschen im Kreis die äh Geschichte, aber gibt's hier irgendwie einen Zeitplan? Also ist äh irgendwie äh,
irgendwie schon absehen.
Gerade nicht äh so wiedergeben. Vielleicht gibt's den da schon, aber ähm.
Ähm weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Also ist wieder da und hat schon eine Reihe an Unterstützern, wie das so wie das so ist, ne. Jetzt muss man irgendwie äh Gas geben, damit man das irgendwie verhindern kann.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieses Podcasts hat diese Avas-Org Petition schon über sechshunderttausend Unterzeichner.
Tja.
Und strebt jetzt irgendwie die Millionen an. Ja. Bin ich mal gespannt, wie sich das weiter entwickelt.
Gut.
Dann hatten wir die das große Thema jetzt der.
Ich glaube des gestrigen Tages, so äh Facebook-Abmahnungen,
ähm und zwar hat äh jemand eine eine Abmahnung bekommen, der also aufm Facebookprofil hatte und da gibt's ja irgendwie wohl diese Pinnwand, die man dann da drunter hat und.
Ja und und da kann dann jeder reinschreiben oder was, ne? Da da kann man dann jemanden an die Pinnwand schreiben. Ja.
An die Wand schreiben. Ran sprayen.
Graffiti, Schmiererei, ja, Schmierreise.
Wall halt. Kannst halt irgendwo hingehen und dann ist an die Häuserwand, an die, ans Garagentor ranpinkeln.
Vielleicht ist es doch was für mich mit diesem Facebook.
Kannst du den Kreativen anpink.
Sven Regener. Nee, also ähm,
Mensch lebt, hat ein Facebookprofil, äh kommt ein anderer und postet etwas auf diese Pinnwand.
Das ist ein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Foto. Und jetzt geht die Abmahnung,
an den Betreiber dieser Facebookseite,
Also wegen seiner Pinnwand und bezieht sich auf äh Paragraph neunzehn A Urheberrechtsgesetz, öffentliche Zugänglichmachung eines Lichtbilds,
und sagt also hier ähm wir wollen ähm hier ist unsere Abmahnung, wir wollen, dass wir es unverzüglich entfernt äh sag mal, wie lange das dort war,
Und danach berechnen wir dann den Schadensersatz, den wir auch noch von dir haben wollen. Was mich ein bisschen wundert, weil wenn ich vermute doch mal, dass bei Facebook dann schon irgendwie, wenn ich da eine Pinnwand schreibe, dass da auch das Datum beisteht, ja. Na gut, aber das äh haben sie vielleicht nicht gesehen.
Das entscheidende ist, diese Pinnwand ist ja kein Angebot des Facebook-Nutzers, sondern irgendwie standardmäßig bei dem Profil dabei und er hat keinen Einfluss auf den Inhalt, ja? Ähm,
Das heißt, ähm diese Abmahnung scheint eigentlich relativ leicht anfechtbar zu sein, weil ähm er tatsächlich nicht der der Anbieter ist. Man kann das also vergleichen, argumentiert dann der,
ähm Udo Fetter. Selbst wenn das jetzt nicht ohnehin ein Angebot von Facebook wäre und damit der Nutzer sowieso die falsche, der falsche Adressat für diese Abmahnung ähm,
dann würde das sich verhalten wie bei so einem Block, bei dem man Kommentare hat.
Und da haftet man grundsätzlich auch nicht für die Inhalte, die da äh Nutzer in die Kommentare schreiben. Ähm sondern erst ab dem Moment, wenn man über rechtswidrige Inhalte informiert wurde,
Ich sage, ich persönlich betreibe ja auch eine kleine Internetseite, auf der jeder irgendwie kommentieren kann und da wird häufig irgendwie relativ äh beknackt kommentiert
ähm,
deswegen, es ist jetzt meine persönliche äh mein persönlicher Umgang damit. Deswegen lese ich das auch gar nicht und habe da auch keine Informationen irgendwie drüber, dass ich irgendwie darüber informiert werde, was die Leute da schreiben, weil ich äh mich quasi gezielt,
damit nicht auseinandersetzen möchte, das irgendwie zu moderieren. Weil dann habe ich ja Kenntnis davon.
Überhaupt diese Facebook.
Ich habe kein Facebook. Das ist irgendwie die Pinnwand. Ich glaube, das ist das, wenn man auf der Seite von einer Person ist. Und dann kannst du da hinschreiben, hey, hier äh.
Ja, ich kann sein, ich ich stelle ja immer alles ab, wenn die irgendwas Neues machen. Schalte ich das immer alles ab und habe irgendwie eine komplett andere Sichtweise, glaube ich.
Also jetzt, jetzt noch ganz kurz zu den zu den Blog-Kommentaren, also wenn ich einen Blog betreibe und da oder wenn ich irgendwie eine Seite betreibe, dann können Nützer äh unten Kommentare schreiben, sei es irgendwie ein Forum, sei es in Blogs oder sonst was, ist die Rechtslage so,
ähm ab dem Moment, wo ich darüber informiert werde,
und trotz dieser Kenntnis das nicht entferne in dem Moment bin ich ähm haftbar,
Aber für diese erste, für diese erste Hinweis, für diese Kenntnismachung,
in Kenntnissetzung. Ähm die sollte mir eigentlich nix äh kann mich nichts kosten und ist völlig in Ordnung. Ich muss aber dann halt in dem Moment, wo ich dann sage, nee, äh halte ich irgendwie für nicht. Ähm,
Gesetzeswidrig lasse ich drauf ankommen. In dem Moment bin ich haftbar, weil man hat mir quasi nachgewiesen, dass ich das weiß und das dulde. Und in dem Moment, wenn ich äh verantwortlich. Finde ich eigentlich eine ganz ähm.
Ist eigentlich eine ganz sinnvolle Regelung. Und wie gesagt, das ist auch der Grund, warum ich persönlich das jetzt aber kein juristischer Rat wäre, merkt, dass ich hier andauernd ihr Rata zu juristischen Themen äh an Anfang der Sendung von mir geben muss
weiß, dass da auf meinen Rat nicht zu bauen ist, aber das ist eben der Grund, warum ich bei bei User Generation auch gezielt nicht moderiere,
Also weil ich das nicht mache und weil mir das auch im Zweifelsfall auf den Geist gehen würde, weil.
Jetzt so blöd, ne.
Müsst ihr alle lesen. Ja, bei Logbuch Netzpolitik moderieren wir.
Und wie?
Da haben wir echt eine, also ich meine, keine Ahnung von.
Kommen nur die besten und gefährlichsten Kommentare durch.
Ja, da kann man sogar mit einem Lob manchmal daran scheitern, dass ein anderer ein noch größeres Lob ja, dass man also nicht dem unseren Qualitätsansprüchen an ein Lob entspricht. Ähm ja.
So geht's mir immer ja immer wenn ich bei Facebook schaue.
Wo jetzt was ist, wovon die Leute reden und wie man das ein oder ausschalten kann. Ich finde es einfach nicht.
Ja, das ist ja bei dem Konzept, also ich meine.
Aber nie. Ich meine, geht's noch?
Du, ich glaube, das ist echt, du bist einfach.
Doch hier ist stets Pinnwand.
Ja. So und jetzt mach mal schnell geschütztes Bild rein. Also um das um das Thema zum Ausschuss zu bringen,
die da Ahnung von haben, sagen, dass man da eher ähm beruhigt sein soll, ja, also weil jetzt weil's natürlich irgendwie alle loslegten, huh, ähm,
Demnächst äh regnet das hier Abmahnungen wegen Facebook. Äh diese Furcht ist eher.
Unbegründet. Ne, ist doch auch mal was Schönes.
Also schön weiter hier Urheber. Also.
Nee, also wenn, dann, das, das ist auch die ganze Sache, die mich an dem, an dem Thema äh irgendwie wundert, ist, wenn wenn da jemand an die Pinnwand schreibt, warum mahnen die dann nicht wenigstens denjenigen ab, der an die Pinnwand geschrieben hat?
Also da steht doch dann auch drunter, äh äh Mensch B, Person B hat dieses B.
Und.
Ja
Ja, also da kümmert sich jetzt irgendwie eine Anwaltskanzlei rum, aber scheint irgendwie den Medienrummel, den es ausgelöst hat, nicht wirklich wert zu sein, dieses Thema.
Erstaunlich, wie wenig Sachen ich hier irgendwie auf diesem ich weiß auch nicht, warum mir dieses Facebook so eine Angsthain jagt. Ich bin ja nun wirklich nicht so ein Aluhut, aber dieses System, das ist mir einfach zu creepy.
Gut, weiter geht's. Ja. WLAN. Nee. Nee, Entschuldigung. Urheberrecht. Oh ja. Mein Kopf gehört mir. Letzten Donnerstag, glaube ich. Ah. Herrlich.
Urheberrecht? Urheberrecht. Oh ja. Mein Kopf gehört mir letzten Donnerstag, glaube ich, Handelsblatt. Herrlich. Wahnsinn. Ähm die haben, also Han.
Das sind aber auch wirklich derzeit die Trolle schlechthin, oder? Also das Handelsblatt, ich glaube, das ist äh
die Trollen einfach das Netz und denen geht's da gar nicht so sehr äh um eine Position, sondern die wollen einfach gnadenlos Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen und äh,
dass äh scheint mir so ein bisschen das Konzept zu sein, also journalistisch lässt sich das irgendwie alles mittlerweile nicht mehr nachvollziehen. Aber was ist jetzt Neues passiert.
Also journalistisch lässt sich das auch noch nicht mal mehr rechtfertigen, was sie da machen.
Ja. Was ist jetzt passiert? Sie haben irgendwie dick aufgemacht, war das Titelseite? War das irgendwie nur online.
Nee, nee, das war, das war ein äh, das war Print. Und das war ähm nicht die Titelseite, sondern vor der Titelseite nochmal so ein, ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt, da gibt.
So so ein extra Cover, was da so da vorgetackert ist so. Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt. Das hat einen Namen.
Bekommen, dann war die komplette erste Seite ständig wieder auf meinem Kopf, gehört mir äh hundert Kreative wehren sich im Handelsblatt gegen die Enteignung so, dann hast du aufgeklappt und dann war nochmal die normale Handelsplatte Seite.
Also so wie so ein Kondom. Hm.
Und dann hatten sie in der im Handelsblatt dann selber relativ weit hinten dann sechs Doppelseiten. Irgendwie ähm,
wo dann irgendwie erstmal ein sehr ähm,
Also wirklich sehr, sehr reißerischer Text dann irgendwie wahr und dir vor allem irgendwie die Piraten so angriff, ja? Ähm als würden die, also sie würden jetzt hier die Enteignung der Inhalte, Produzenten ähm,
und äh sollte man sich nicht gefallen lassen, deswegen hat Handelsblatt jetzt hier hundert äh hundert äh Kreative oder was,
geschafft, die äh die irgendwie sich jetzt zum Thema äußern und wie ähm,
Weiß, dass sie dann sehr schön mal äh gezählt hat. Das waren also sechsundzwanzig Kreativschaffende, siebenundvierzig Manager aus der Verwertungsindustrie, acht Politiker, sechs Akademar
Akademiker und irgendwie acht Funktionäre von Branchenverbänden, also ähm ja, nicht wirklich so viele Kreativschaffende, wobei Marcel dann, glaube ich, sogar bei den Kreativschaffenden noch irgendwelche Werber mit dazu gezählt,
also.
Manager von was? Also Manager von Firmen, die für sich in Anspruch nehmen, also Verwerter sozusagen.
Nee, die tatsächlich Verwerter, ja, die wirklich so hauptsächlich aus dieser Verwertungsindustrie kommt, ne? Also ich habe das, kriegst du auch irgendwie Augenbluten, wenn du das irgendwie liest, ne? Also das äh.
Ja auch Rössler und so, ich meine, was.
Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger.
Wo ist denn der Rösler kreativ.
Erfinden schlechter äh Metaphern vielleicht oder so, aber.
Ja, nee, also äh.
Ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Also erstaunlich, ich kann einfach nur sagen.
Dieses, es ist ganz offensichtliche Kampagne, äh nix mit Journalismus zu tun, dann noch dieser dieser denke ich auch relativ ähm,
Also hinkt ohnehin und ist auch sehr, sehr übel anmaßend. Dieser Vergleich zum ähm oder dieser Bezug zu dieser mein Bauch gehört mir, ja,
abtreibungsbewegung siebziger Jahre oder so, ne? Gesagt haben, mein Bauch gehört mir und äh ich habe abgetrieben. Also das jetzt ihr.
Siebziger war das die Achtziger? War das nicht so eine so eine Stern, so ein Stern-Cover?
Ne, das Sterncover war, wir haben abgetrieben. Und dieses dieses äh Bauchgehalt, mir müsste, glaube ich, siebziger. War doch damals, weiß ja doch, Tim, Mensch.
Richtig, genau. Das war so diese äh genau, das war diese Initiative, ja. Ja, damals, ja genau.
Äh also da da war ich da habe, war ich noch nicht geboren, also auch akut von Abtreibung bedroht, wahrscheinlich noch. So dann ähm.
Also diese dieses,
dieses offensichtliche Kampagne in einem wirklich beängstigenden Ausmaß ähm echt erstaunlich. Also alle äh wir hatten das ja schon gesagt, so diese diese Vorhersage, dass jetzt im Urheberrecht wirklich die fette Kampagne kommt,
Diese Vorhersage ist also absolut zu äh eingetreten und ähm,
Wenn man sich anschaut, auf welchem Niveau das da wirklich geführt wird, äh das ist dann äh umso erschreckender, ja und ähm.
Zumindest, was die Parteitagsbeschlüsse angeht ähm,
ohne das jetzt konkret am Beispiel untermauern zu können, aber das weiß ich. Also so aus den Gesprächen im Team bei Netzpolitik org so, wo sich ja andere mit diesen Themen auseinandersetzen, ist es immer so, im Moment so, wenn du nach Parteitagsbeschlüssen gehst
dann hat die ähm Piratenpartei eigentlich im Moment eine relativ ähm nicht besonders radikale,
zum Urheberrecht,
Also irgendwie diese diese Vollenteignung oder was auch, wovon auch immer da die Rede ist, äh kann man da wirklich nicht unterstellen, ja, also trotzdem hat dann die Piratenpartei irgendwie mit einem äh,
Blogpost einhunderteins Piraten für ein neues Urheberrecht gekontert, in dem dann eben auch ja
wirklich mal gesagt wird, ein neues Urheberrecht, wo dann,
also ich, wie gesagt, ich kann mich ja nicht so genau erinnern, wer jetzt wirklich außer äh Michael Seemann ernsthaft sagte, es soll gar kein
gar keine äh Urheberrechte mehr geben, ja. Das das Problem ist hauptsächlich in dieser Debatte, wie es ja das Handelsblatt da auch genau vormacht.
Das Urheberrecht und Verwertungsrechte nicht getrennt werden,
In dieser gesamten Debatte das Urheberrecht kannst du ja gar nicht veräußern. Das verlierst du nicht. Das hast du, dass dir angeboren. Das hast du oder ja nicht angeboren, aber das hast du ja selbst, wenn äh wenn du deine Werke und deine CC-Lizenz stellst,
dann ist das ja,
eine Maßnahme, die du ergreifst im Rahmen deines Rechtes als Urheber. Was, was nicht veräußerbar ist? Und dieses dieses dein Recht als Urheber ähm.
Schränkst du dann in dieser Lizenz maximal ein? Trotzdem bleibt es dein Recht, mit dem du eben auch diese CC-Lizenzierung wieder rückgängig machen kannst. Mit allen Problemen, die danach kommen,
ähm und aus diesem urheberrecht gibt's eben,
eines der Möglichkeiten die Verwertungsrichter an jemand anderen abzutreten. Und das ist das, was alle kreativen im Moment machen.
Das Standardmodell des Vertriebs irgendwie einer kreativen Leistung ist, sei es irgendwie als Journalist, der das
Vertriebsrecht für den Text irgendwie an seinen an seine Redaktion oder den Verlag abtritt, sei es der Musiker, ähm der diese Verwertungsrechte an die äh an sein Label abtritt
oder wo auch immer sonst irgendwo kreative Leistungen verbracht werden. Ich denke, da ist ja der Kern äh der Urheberrechtsdebatte. Ja? Und ähm.
Ja, was ich in der ganzen Debatte vermisse, sind einfach mal konkrete äh Vorschläge. Also es wird halt viel behauptet, das ginge ja alles nicht und das geht ja auch alles nicht. Ähm nur sich mal wirklich zu konkreten Aussagen,
Verschärfungen und weiterer Bekämpfung, ja, die sind natürlich sehr konkret die Aussagen, aber äh unserer Auffassung nach halt wenig zielführend ähm gibt's halt auch gerade im Piratenlager
Also ich habe das schon immer für eine Achillesperse gehalten der Piraten, ja. Ich
Kann mich da noch erinnern, dass ich irgendwann mal bei so einem der ersten Parteitage auch dabei war, wurde dann so ein erstes Papier da äh beschlossen werden sollte, so dass das Ganze halt so diesem ersten Echo der Zensursula äh Bewegung, wo so spürbar war, jetzt geht's los,
ähm wie da einfach keinerlei Konsens herrschte,
Also der einzige Konsens ist der, dass man sich da eigentlich gar nicht drüber einig ist. Irgendwas muss halt äh getan werden, aber alle ruderten so ein bisschen
mit den Armen, so und es gibt da irgendwie keine erkennbare Person oder Gruppe, die da in irgendeiner Form
auch die Meinungsführerschaft ausbildet oder mal durch konkrete Darstellungen des Themas in der Öffentlichkeit oder auch
vielleicht gibt's eine interne Öffentlichkeit äh innerhalb der Piratenpartei, wo das geschieht.
Die ich nicht zur Kenntnis genommen habe, ja, aber wenn das auf diskutiert wird, ist das sowieso erstmal eine ganz andere Geschichte. Äh man hat immer so das Gefühl, je nachdem, welchen äh äh Pirat of the day sich die Medien jetzt gerade mal wieder auf den Stuhl setzen,
Man halt die oder die sich geboten, aber es hat halt keinerlei Linie. Es hat äh also vor allem hat es.
Das ist genau das Ding, was ich vermisse, also mir ist noch nicht mal klar, wohin man eigentlich will, ja, also alle sind sich irgendwie einig in dem, was sie nicht wollen, aber keiner ist sie auch nur im Ansatz irgendwie einig, irgendwie erkennbar, wohin die Reise gehen soll, ja.
Also das ist das ist genau die Achillesverse, die du gerade ansprachst und da sieht man jetzt auch, wie sie irgendwie, wie sie zuschlägt, ja. Das äh,
Es gibt natürlich die Ansätze da konkrete Vorschläge zu machen. Also wir haben, wir haben ja Flatter. Sehe ich so als als sehe ich nach wie vor als irgendwie, dass,
den konkretesten Ansatz, mal irgendwie Verwertung, Verwerter auszusetzen und konkreten Bezug zwischen Urheber und Nutzer herzustellen. Wir haben die,
CC Lizenzen, die leider irgendwie ähm na ja, ein Finanzierungsmodell zumindest nicht eingebaut haben und dann sich auf relativ wenige äh prominente Beispiele stützen müssen,
bei denen es dann mal geklappt hat, ja.
Bei Sven Regener angesprochen, wo dann wie gesagt irgendwie Zeit äh Zeit lang irgendwie bestimmte nein in Schmelzplatten irgendwie wirklich als Creative rausgehauen hat. Und dann dieses diese Premium
Produkte gemacht hat. Die hat dann gesagt, ja okay, kann jeder runterladen und ab vierzig äh Euro
dieses Album dann in irgendwie im Digipack und achtzig Euro ist da noch eine DVD dabei und äh dreihundert Euro ist eine Unterschrift drauf oder tausend Euro ist mal eine LP dabei oder so. Ähm,
der hat und damit ja wirklich sehr, sehr gute äh sehr gute finanzielle Erfahrungen gemacht hat. Ähm,
So und dann gibt es vom CCC äh formuliert.
Ungefähr vor einem Jahr, äh, glaube ich, äh, der Öffentlichkeit vorgestellt, die Kultur werden mag.
Ziehen sie eine Kulturwertmarke.
Die leider irgendwie sehr viel Kritik für ihre für ihren äh für ihren Namen bekommen hat. Aber wo es also darum,
Ja, ja, ja, gut. Äh da da erinnere ich mich dann auch wieder an Gregors Ausspruch vom letzten, weil sie ihr redet über Inhalte, ja. Das ist der Fehler, den ihr macht. Ähm.
Ohne das Konzept jetzt konkret ähm.
Konkret irgendwie äh genauer nochmal zu besprechen, aber der man könnte sich das in einem Satz vorstellen, wie so eine Art staatliches Flatter.
Gibt's irgendwie einen Topf, da ist alles drin, woher dieses Geld das Geld sei durch Steuern oder sonst was eingetrieben und das wird dann irgendwie verteilt über äh über in einem fletterartigen,
Zyklus. Das ist natürlich ein sehr ähm.
Theoretisches Konzept, was da entfaltet wird, aber wenigstens mal ein Vorschlag, ja?
Und der ist eben da und der könnte debattiert werden. Der hat bei weitem nicht die ähm Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, die die Eloaboriertheit, diese dieses Papers, in denen das vorgeschlagen wird, eigentlich mal,
zumindest verdient hätte.
Das Problem bei diesen ganzen Vorschlägen ist auch, dass sie sich sehr an der deutschen Landschaft äh orientieren und,
Ich denke, dass man dieser ganzen ich meine, das ist eine der internationalsten Debatten überhaupt.
Ja? So unterschiedlich Copy-Reit und Urheberrecht et cetera äh sind, ist es irgendwie klar, also mindestens auf europäischer Ebene, man ist jetzt einfach gezwungen, da auch einfach internationaler zu denken. Zumal das Problem,
ja auch in sich vollständig internationalisiert ist.
Durch das Internet, durch die Verfügbarkeit von Daten überall, durch äh mega Upload sitzt da in Neuseeland, et cetera. Also das das ist ein Problem, das kann man jetzt mit so einer deutschen äh,
Änderungen, ja, wo wir hier so sozialverliebt,
mit unseren Verteilungsmechanismen, mit irgendwie Kopierer Abgabe und GEMA et cetera ja im Prinzip solche Ideen sind ja auch noch nicht mal neu, ja, also dieses Ganze, wir brauchen einen Verteilungsapparat, ja den gibt es. Das Problem ist nur, dass diese Verteilungsapparate
auch nicht so funktionieren, wie wir das wollen. Und das äh man eigentlich auch in jeder Konstellation immer wieder feststellt, ja die Etablierten haben's einfacher.
Das gilt am Ende sogar für sowas wie Flatter, ja, was ja auch immer so ein so ein Vorwurf ist und das, das, das, das, die, die eh schon bekannt sind, et cetera natürlich mehr davon profitieren, aber das ist, glaube ich, ein, ein generelles
Kulturproblem. Trotzdem, das weiter zu öffnen und zu demokratisieren und eben diese Tragfähigkeit solcher Verteilungsmechanismen breiter zu streuen, was
eben ein Ansatz ist, der sich unter anderem in dieser
Kultur äh äh werden mag, äh Idee als auch generell der Idee der Kulturflatrate wiederfindet. Aber man hat natürlich auch das Problem, dass man eben den Markt als Seuchen dabei ziemlich weit außen vor lässt. Kulturwerkmark,
Kommt ja dann eben auch so mit dieser Idee des Freikaufens. Ja, das ist gar nicht mal nur so um eine eine,
Von Geldern geht, sondern eben dann auch so mit ja und wenn dann genug bezahlt ist, dann ist es eben auch frei. Also es ist,
sehr schwer zu diskutieren, insbesondere auf so einem internationalen Level. Und ich denke halt irgendwie, auch wenn ich jetzt selber da nicht mit Lösungen kommen kann,
Am Ende muss sich irgendetwas durchsetzen, was eine wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr einfache Grundidee hat,
Irgendwas, was nicht so kompliziert ist, dass man's auf zwanzig Seiten beschreiben muss und dreißigtausend Podcasts durchführen muss, bis es irgendeiner mal versteht.
Und diese Linie fehlt und da ist so im Prinzip auch das goldene Osterei, äh wo sich die Piraten mal auf die Suche machen sollten, wenn sie in den öffentlichen Debatten äh ums Urheberrecht äh noch weiter bestehen wollen, ne, weil Achillesverse,
nochmal sagen, man merkt es,
da wird jetzt kräftig dran rumgesägt, weil die Medien und auch in gewisser Hinsicht die anderen TM so ein bisschen riechen, dass da etwas, was immer am lautesten proklamiert wird, am wenigsten vertreten werden kann.
Was, was sie, was die Piratenpartei im Prinzip braucht, äh ist so ein Elevator Pitch für ein neues Urheberrecht. Drei Sätze äh Sitze irgendwo bei äh im Fernsehen oder was sagt einer Urheberrecht? Da musst du drei Sätze sagen, so und so
wird die Welt besser für alle. Zack!
Und dann äh lasst die äh lasst die anderen äh durchdrehen und sich fragen überlegen, wie sie wie sie dir wieder eine Falle stellen können. Im Moment ist es halt so, dass man irgendwie schreit, äh ja Piraten wollen uns enteignen.
Ja, kann man schöne.
Gehört mir und sie sind tatsächlich halt wirklich.
Eine schöne Geschäftsordnung für einen Piratenparteitag draus machen, hier zwanzig Sekunden fünf Sätze und am besten äh ist das, was dann am meisten angenommen wird. Genau oder.
Einfach mal ein Pat machen. Aber da muss auf jeden Fall etwas äh passieren, weil wir wirklich eben grade sehen.
Ist auch ein interessanter Test für so Systeme wie Liquid Feedback, weil man ja eigentlich gerade erwarten möchte, dass diese äh wohl
gepriesenen Systeme, die ja sehr viel Potential in sich haben, äh grade an der Stelle eigentlich in der Lage sein müssten, die Intelligenz nach oben zu spüren.
Wir sind offen für Hinweise der Piraten, die hier zuhören, die unter Umständen schon den passenden Link jetzt äh in der linken Hand äh jonglieren, ja, äh wo solche Initiativen,
zu sehen sind. Ich persönlich kenne sie nicht, was vor allem daran liegt, dass ich mich jetzt nicht zu intensiv damit beschäftige.
Trotzdem bleibt aber natürlich also egal, welchen Vorschlag jetzt irgendjemand fürs für eine Urheberrechtsreform macht, im Zweifelsfall wird der eben die Verwertungs ähm die Verwert her,
nicht in dem Ausmaß berücksichtigen, indem sie das für richtig halten und die die Gegenargumentation oder für,
dem die das ganz gerne hätten, damit sie Geld bekommen. Und in dem Fall wird diese Argumentation immer,
ähm auf der Schiene angegriffen werden, dass das Modell nicht tragfähig wäre, ja. Also es wird immer, egal, wenn du jetzt irgendwie diese Verwertungsgesellschaften wirklich gezielt angreifst, mit einem mit einem, egal, wie auch immer, gearteten Konzept. Ähm.
Dann werden die argumentieren, dass dann irgendwie, dann können wir aber keine Filme wie Avatar oder sonst was mehr drehen äh und äh so weiter,
Ich meine, die ganze Filmindustrie ist in der Regel irgendwie.
Bin mir auch total sicher, dass es dann keinerlei Blockbuster mehr geben wird. So, nichts mehr gibt, was alle mögen.
Kultur stirbt, ja.
Aber das sind also ich meine, die gesamte Debatte des Urheberrechtes ähm,
Inzwischen so ausgefochten und jeder hat seinen Senf dazugegeben, man kennt jeden Player darin. Man man kennt deren Interessen, man kennt deren Impulse und deren ähm
deren ähm Slogans, ja und jetzt ist es wirklich an der Zeit höchsten Zeit,
sich da hinzusetzen und sagen, passt auf, Freunde, da, da, da und da. Und sich wirklich mal hinzusetzen und ein Konzept wirklich,
und auch durch zu argumentieren. Es liegt alles auf dem Tisch. Und im Moment
Genau das, was du sagst, mit der Achillesverse ähm hat da keiner was und jetzt wird draufgehauen. Und dann wird jetzt deswegen kann sich das Handelsblatt es auch erlauben,
sich irgendwie so weit aus dem Fenster zu lehnen mit so einem
plumpen Kampagnen-Journalismus mit dieser mit dieser vorgehefteten Titelseite, weil sie genau wissen, da wird keiner kommen und uns irgendwie mal äh da irgendwie als wirklich mal als blöd darstellen, mit dem, was wir da sagen.
Und das äh das kriegen wir jetzt gerade auf den,
Wir oder die Piraten oder sagen wir mal das das Internet oder wer auch immer fliegt das jetzt gerade um die Ohren, dieser Umstand.
Ohne es jetzt zu sehr in die Länge treiben zu wollen, aber wo du gerade sagst, so hier, äh die ganzen Slogans und die ganzen Forderungen, et cetera, die sind ähm bekannt,
ähm gibt's eigentlich so analog zu Liquid Feedback eigentlich auch so eine Visualisierung, so ein weißt du, so,
Schöne informatische Aufgabe, ja, wenn man wenn alles bekannt ist, wer was sagt und was fordert, dann müsste sich das ja auch irgendwie so als Graf äh äh abbilden lassen, also dass man das so in der Art als Testsystem macht, so wie viel Ausgleich,
Position würde man sozusagen auf äh erzielen, wenn man jetzt hier diese äh Bedingungen macht. Nicht, dass ich glaube, dass man wirklich alles mit Software erschlagen kann.
Ein Computermodell, was was von vorne herein einfach, wo du immer nur so mit Relationen sagst, widerspricht Dingens auf Konfliktauflösbar durch.
Oder so. Ja, welche, mit welchen Aussagen könnte man hier irgendeinen Konsens äh schaffen?
Die Welturheberrechtsmodellformel.
Ja so ein Politik Politikprolog.
Ja, mach mal.
Okay, dann müssen wir jetzt aber hier aufhören mit dem Podcast. Okay, alles klar.
Okay, alles klar. An die Tasten.
Ja, war's das?
Ja, kann man noch kurz erwähnen, ähm jetzt, nachdem wir das Thema mit den ähm Wählernanbietern,
Ähm die Säulen gibt's also jetzt eine Initiative der Hamburger Bürgerschaft schon seit einiger Zeit, die sagen, wir wollen äh dass die Wählern Anbieter
einem Excess Provider nach Paragraph acht Telemediengesetz gleichgestellt werden und damit halt irgendwie aus der Haftung gezogen werden und im Berliner, der Berliner Senat,
Ich denke, auf Initiative der SPD, glaube ich, will jetzt auch im Bundesrat aktiv werden. Und äh
Die formulieren also eine Haftung für
für unbefugte Nutzer soll jedenfalls dann nicht eintreten, wenn er förderliche technische Schutzmaßnahmen ihrem Zweck entsprechend wirksam gegen eine unbefugte Drittnutzung des Zusatzzugangs eingesetzt worden sind. Der Satz
besagt gar nichts, ja, weil ich meine, wer ist ein unbefugter Nutzer? Ähm und dann hier zu.
Nicht unbefugte Nutzer, sondern eine unbefugte Nutzung. Also im Sinne von, ich lese das als äh Fallshering muss verhindert werden.
Ja, genauso lese ich's nämlich auch. Hier hier bedarf es einer Regelung, die die Anforderungen an die jeweils einzusetzenden Schutzmaßnahmen auch unter Zumutbarkeitskriterien eindeutig und allgemein verständlich definiert.
Genau und zwar so eindeutig und allgemein verständlich definiert, wie dieser Satz selber äh allgemein und eindeutig verständlich ist.
Aber ähm Hintergrund dabei ist ja, dass in Deutschland äh in in Berlin ja auch diese ähm,
diese Freifunnker sind da ja auch irgendwie gerade mit dem mit Berlin am sprechen. Da soll's ja irgendwie auch so ein so eine Art freies, so ein Bürgernetz oder Bürger.
Ja, die Idee verfängt, in Berlin komischerweise tatsächlich ein bisschen.
Tatsächlich, aber aber auch seit Jahren irgendwie ohne großartigen Fortschritt, aber es gibt das irgendwie, ne? Und diese reden irgendwie darüber. Und ähm,
Ich meine jetzt, wenn es schon an irgendwelche Kriterien oder sonst was gebunden ist, ob ich für meinen WLAN-Zugang hafte oder nicht, ähm kann ich persönlich sagen, dat riecht schon nach Ärger.
Ja gut, aber was ich hier sehr interessant finde hier an dieser ganzen Initiative ist, dass es von Berlin ausgeht und ich denke, das hat einfach auch ein bisschen was mit dem Oberholz zu tun
Nicht mit dem Oberholz als solchen, sondern eher repräsentativ für die Problematik. Wer in Berlin wohnt, kennt die Diskussion von außen, ist vielleicht nicht ganz so klar, aber hier geht's dann so ein bisschen grad so die Angst um, dass
Berlin nicht mehr cool ist. Ja, also mit dieser, dieses ganze Clubsterben et cetera, das ist so mittlerweile ein, ein, ein erkanntes Problem. Ja, nicht, dass,
dagegen getan wird, aber.
Prenzlauer Berg ist das Problem daran zu erkennen, dass es keine Clubs mehr gibt, ne.
Ja, genau, so, aber das äh,
Das ist, glaube ich, auch den, dem der Politik so lange egal gewesen, ja, bis sie jetzt verstanden hat, dass einfach ihre Cashcow Nummer eins in dieser Stadt darunter leiden wird,
Die Touristen kommen hierher und suchen nach dem geilen Nachtleben für das Berlin weltweit bekannt ist. Ja, und für diese Hypnis und Coolness und haste nicht gesehen,
Ja und auch so diese ganze fair und wir sind hier irgendwie die die digitale Boheme im Kaffee. Ja bloß Internetzugang gibt's halt keinen mehr, weil äh,
Ja, ich meine, dass das führt einfach mal wirklich zu Punktabzug im im Bereich Coolness und das äh.
Ich meine, irgendwann könnte sich der Slogan dieser Stadt in den Armen aber trotzdem nicht sexy äh,
So und dann dann ist hier wirklich äh dann das ist wirklich ein Problem. Ja, ich meine, Berlin kann einiges aushalten. Schulden und wirtschaftlicher Niedergang, alles, aber nicht mehr sexy sein, das geht hier einfach mal gar nicht.
Ja, also.
Gut so. Gut so, dass sich da was tut, aber du hast natürlich recht. Das ist eine schwammige Formulierung, weil Prinzip,
Aber in dieser Formulierung, dass diese generelle Problematik.
Der, der, der Hilflosigkeit gegenüber dem Angebot von Internetzugang an sich,
Ja, in dem Moment, wo ich sage, ja, mein WLAN ist offen, sollen die Leute doch hier das Internet benutzen, so. Dann kommt man genau in dieses Problem. Dann gibt's jetzt ein Vergehen, so und ich meine
Wir sind uns ja auch einig, es gibt ja auch Aktivitäten im Netz, die sehr wohl strafwürdig sind. Ja
Wenn ich jetzt anfange, äh irgendwelche äh äh Systeme zu dedorsten und runterzufahren und äh äh Hackerattacken zu starten und äh Datenklauer und Pipapo oder Leute verleumgen, das sind ja auch alles Vorfälle. Die sind einfach mehr als fragwürdig.
Und äh die Politik äh ist einfach an der Stelle etwas hilflos, weil sie eben nicht so richtig weiß
vorgehen soll und eine dieser Sachen ist halt dieses, naja, dann müssen wir halt da den Zugang einschränken. Ist natürlich Quatsch, weil man am Ende des Tages diesen Zugang nie wirklich einschränken wird. Man muss damit leben, dass das Netz irgendwie offen ist, aber so ist halt einfach gerade die Gemengelage.
Jetzt hat man genau äh das Problem, dass es natürlich für einen Kaffee äh irgendwie nicht zumutbar ist, sich mit diesem Scheiß rumzuschlagen. Alles, was man jetzt gemacht hat, ist, dass man da so einen äh
anderen Provider jetzt einsetzt, der dann in einer anderen Legislative unterliegt und und auf einmal äh,
Ja, geht, geht das, was vorher irgendwie nicht ging. Nur es ist für alle total anstrengend und umständlich und kostet auch noch extra Geld. Das ist wirklich bekloppt.
Wahrscheinlich muss sich da der Pragmatismus einfach durchsetzen, dass man sagt, naja, kann man halt nix machen.
Was ja äh in in bestimmten anderen, wenn man da irgendwie offensichtlich nach nach Paragraf acht Themen gehen, Excess Provider ist ähm.
In gewisser Form auch so ist, ne, dass man dass man dann zumindest nicht haftet. Also es es darf einfach kein Risiko für mich sein, anderen Wählern.
Also ich denke ja gut Urheberrechtsverletzung hin oder her, aber ähm.
Da muss man sich ja dann auch nochmal überlegen, wie äh wie groß wirklich der Schaden da ähm,
tatsächlich, dann ist dadurch, dass diese Urheberrechtsverletzungen begangen wird, wobei die Abmahnungen, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ja, in,
Der Regel nicht wegen des Herunterladens, sondern wegen der Zugänglichmachung,
Erfolgen und äh es ohnehin sage ich mal, schlechter Stil ist, ein äh geteiltes WLAN durch irgendwelche tollen ähm zu belasten.
Ähm ja, aber.
Obwohl auch genau das gehört dann halt auch einfach mal dazu, ist halt einfach Netz.
Das ist einfach ein WLAN, ja, muss man machen, ja. Ist Netz, ja, muss muss gehen.
Gehe halt auch dahin also
Auch so Kaffees, wo ich einfach bewusst hingehe, nicht nur, weil sie einen guten Kaffee haben, sondern weil ich auch weiß, dass ich da einfach ordentlich ins Netz kriege. Das ist für mich schon entscheidend, ob die irgendwie nur äh zehn Megabit haben oder oder fünfzig Megabit haben.
Du suchst deine Kaffees nach der Bandbreite aus. Ja, klar, also.
Klar, wenn das irgendwie nicht performt äh und ich muss halt noch einen Upload fertigmachen und so und der ist halt äh wie wichtig und nebenbei will ich halt die Zeit nutzen und da so ein bisschen äh vor mich hin konsumieren. Ist ja genau das der Grund, warum es da überhaupt WLAN gibt.
Also diese, dieser Anspruch, der der sollte äh eigentlich jedem ähm verständlich sein und auch äh denke ich mal durchgesetzt werden, dass man sagt, es soll einfach mal überall irgendwie Netz geben für die Leute,
ohne irgendwie groß großartig und äh.
Kriegt das ja dadurch eh nicht durch diese Verfolgung ohnehin nicht eingedämmt. Das hat sich ja nun schon schon lange gezeigt, als es da einfach ein ein Popanz, den man sich da aufgebaut hat, mit irgendwie IP-Adressen und Pipapo, aber am Ende wird dadurch einfach mal gar nichts verhindert. Das das ist halt einfach das Ding.
Naja.
Irgendwas? Nee, tschüss.
Das war's. Bis bald.